للمره الثانيه في شهر واحد خرج التظاهرات
في انحاء البلاد احتجاجا على مشروع قرار
الحكومي اقترحه الرئيس امان والماكرون
لرفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما عوضا عن 62
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات التي شارك فيها
مئات الالاف تسببت بشل عده قطاعات كالنقل
العموميه المدارس وانتاج الكهرباء والمصاف
النفطيه ووسائل الاعلام حكوميه
هذا ودعت النقابات العمليه الفرنسيه لمزيد
من الاحتجاجات في السابع والحادي عشر من
فبراير المقبل ضد قانون التقاعد الجديد
فيما تضاربت احصائيات المشاركين في
تظاهرات اليوم حيث كانت وزاره الداخليه
الفرنسيه ان مليون و270,000 متظاهر شاركوا
فيها فيما اوضحت النقابات العماليه ان
مليونين و800,000 شاركوا في احتجاجات
اليوم ضد قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]